donc moi je suis Julien effectivement
donc ça fait 17 ans que je suis dans le
métier de la boulangerie et j'avais mon
commerce durant cinq ans et comme mes
confrères j'ai fermé à la même période
avant les fêtes parce que c'était plus
possible les enchaînements des matières
premières les charges et l'électricité
qui nous a complètement plombé quoi donc
au bout d'un moment on peut plus
supporter le travail 90 heures semaine
Julien est-ce que vous pouvez à Monsieur
le Ministre
quel a été votre facture d'électricité
la dernière fois
donc au bout d'un moment on a essayé
comme on a pu de renier sur les marges
on a augmenté les prix on a licencié on
a essayé de faire tout ce qu'on a pu
pour garder le village
sain parce que voilà c'est comme mes
collègues j'étais le seul commerce du
village la seule boulangerie le seul
lieu de rencontre en fait pour que les
les gens les personnes mobilité réduite
les anciens du village se réunissent
donc du coup ouais moi j'ai pris
l'empreinte vraiment l'impression
d'avoir laissé mourir mon village en
fait ouais alors voilà les gens vous ont
vu partir avec vous avez du soutien au
sein du village du soutien pour le coup
de énormément
c'est les gens ils sont encore là
d'ailleurs je reçois des courriers tous
les jours et tout j'ai un soutien
phénoménal et c'est très important le
moral parce que voilà moi j'ai fait une
petite dépression quand même après parce
que voilà on est combien de temps vous
avez tenu votre boulangerie 5 ans 5 ans
c'était votre premier commerce c'était
mon premier commerce ouais ok est-ce que
vous avez vu donc vous c'est le c'est le
coup l'électricité qui a été le coup de
grâce voilà c'est pas j'ai eu ma facture
j'ai fermé mais c'était vraiment le coup
de grâce en fait on a essayé comme je
vous dis les matières premières depuis
cet été les charges qui ont augmenté et
puis bah l'électricité ça a mis le coup
de massue en trop quoi alors est-ce que
vous avez vu parce que vous avez fermé
en décembre vous m'avez dit en décembre
vous avez vu que depuis le début d'année
2023 alors c'est c'est tard pour vous le
projet de va ouvrir pourquoi pas
absolument pas du tout de boulangerie je
me reconvertir dans un autre métier
bac pro ça fait 17 ans que je suis dans
le métier j'étais un grand passionné
j'ai fait des heures de partout j'ai
voyagé dans la France pour le moment
Richir mais voilà à l'heure actuelle le
bilan est là et moi j'ai plus du tout la
passion la fois j'ai plus envie de ce
métier quoi 90 heures par semaine
c'était quoi les horaires de vos
journées je commençais à 2h le matin 3h
et je terminais vers 20h à 20h et vous
étiez tout seul j'avais une vendeuse du
coup qui a perdu son boulot aussi bah
ouais voilà après au-delà de ça voilà on
licencie donc c'est toutes des familles
moi j'avais qu'une salariée mais quand
j'entends des collègues qui perd qui lui
sont aussi 10 salariés c'est 10 familles
derrière avec les enfants le mari ou la
femme quoi c'est c'est dramatique alors
Julien c'est ça oui c'est ça j'espère si
vous avez vu mais donc les règles ont
changé de l'accompagnement par l'état de
la hausse du coup de de l'énergie pour
les artisans les TPE il y a un million
de TPE dans notre pays donc qui est très
petites entreprises c'est à dire moins
de 10 salariés
et des TPE qu'on appelle énergivor
c'est-à-dire des TPE qu'on ne
consommation électrique importante moi
je me suis rendu dans une boulangerie en
région parisienne il y a quelques
semaines j'ai je me suis essayé à la
fabrique du pain c'était pas un succès
mais c'était pas pour ça que j'y étais
mais pour discuter avec l'artisan
boulanger qui effectivement fait face à
une hausse de ses factures parce que en
fait le four utilise beaucoup d'énergie
la conservation au frais aussi en
chambre froide des produits tout ça est
très énergivore et donc ce qu'on a
décidé comme règle vous l'avez peut-être
vu c'est qu'en fait vous avez des
boulangers
qui sont pas soumis à la hausse du prix
d'énergie parce que eux ils ont signé
des contrats sur plusieurs années il y a
il y a un an où il y a six mois et donc
en fait ils ont signé un contrat qui les
engage à leur fournisseur d'énergie
pendant deux ou trois ans et donc eux
l'énergie augmente mais comme ils sont
liés par leur contrat ils sont protégés
et vous avez une partie des boulangers
pour lesquelles ça n'est pas le cas des
boulangers alors il y a une partie des
boulangers qui sont qu'on appelle j'ai
pas utilisé des mots pénis pour les gens
soient mais les boulangers qui sont
soumis au même règle que les Français
donc ils ont une hausse limité à 15% et
il y en a d'autres qui sont qui devaient
là justement signer leur contrat en fin
d'année 2022 c'est peut-être votre cas
j'ai signé un coup et qui du coup vu un
tarif extrêmement élevé et bien ce qu'on
a décidé avec Bruno Le Maire à la
demande du Président de la République
c'est de dire à ces entreprises toutes
celles qu'on signait un contrat trop
cher en fait vous allez pouvoir
renégocier 100 coûts sans frais votre
contrat pour le plafonner un tarif qui
est d'environ 280 par par mégo par
mégawater ce qui veut dire que on prend
on absorbe une partie du cou et on
demande aux fournisseur d'énergie de
faire un effort pour réduire la facture
justement pour pas que les boulang soit
obligé de mettre la clé sous la porte
pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce qu'il
y a un million de TPE donc un million de
très petites entreprises donc des
boulangers et d'autres débouchés qui
peuvent bénéficier de ce dispositif et à
l'heure à laquelle je vous parle on a
reçu 150 000 demandes alors justement il
faut le faire connaître justement
monsieur Mitz Julien si il y avait eu ça
avant est-ce que vous auriez fermé votre
boulangerie ou est-ce que ça vous auriez
est-ce que ça vous aurez sauvé la
question
que ouais j'aurais pu rester au moins au
moins la fin de l'année l'histoire de
voir ce qui se passait encore un peu de
temps parce que c'est vrai que c'est la
course
dans ma tête je avec la comptable on
cherchait la date butoir à laquelle je
devais fermer pour avoir le moins 2
jours aujourd'hui quand on entend des
beaucoup de boulanger qui nous disent
j'avais de la trésorerie je suis obligé
aujourd'hui de la mettre pour payer
l'électricité on a tous fait ça est-ce
que avec cette mesure là les boulangers
qui sont encore en activité vont pouvoir
garder un petit peu de trésorerie ils
vont pouvoir s'en sortir ou bien c'est
ça
c'est toujours un paquet effet vers
l'avant mais comme dit il faut être plus
réactif et plus engageant qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui
pour que voilà redevenir revenir à des
prix corrects toutes les boulangers
puissent perdurer parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que ça ça ferme toutes les
semaines il y a des boulangeries qui
feraient pas un cas isolé hein
pour vous c'est suffisant ou pas non
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait je sais pas je
suis pas ministre à l'heure actuelle
mais qu'est-ce qu'il aurait fallu
justement pardon vous pouvez me parler
vous pouvez me dire qu'est-ce que vous
avez pris de l'énergie déjà en parlant
d'énergie de redevenir à un prix correct
je veux dire on a fait x 3 enfin
certains ont fait x 10 x 12 il aurait
fallu réagir plus tôt pour pouvoir
anticiper les choses en fait je pense
mieux juste monsieur monsieur le
ministre parce que je pense que c'est la
question qui se pose tous les Français
qui nous regardent ce soir est-ce que
les fournisseurs d'énergie à l'heure on
parle
font des bénéfices alors ils ont fait
beaucoup de bénéfices oui certains
notamment ont fait beaucoup de bénéfices
et en fait on a récupéré tout ce qui
était du domaine du bénéfice réalisé à
cause du contexte on a récupéré des
milliards d'euros en fait dans le budget
de la France qu'on a voté que le
Parlement a voté il y a pas longtemps on
a récupéré beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
sur les énergéticiens ce qu'on appelle
les super-profils et surprophy liés à la
crise qu'on traverse après faut
comprendre que le prix du l'énergie la
hausse du prix d'énergie elle est très
directement liée au conflit en Ukraine
et donc il y a eu aussi des dérèglements
des prix je rentre pas dans tous les
dans tous les mécanismes mais nous on a
accumulé pas mal de choses des centrales
qui étaient à la règle elles ont repris
leur fonctionnement quasi normal en tout
cas c'est ça va nettement mieux et puis
on établit le prix de l'électricité à
partir du prix du gaz et comme on a fait
un embargo sur le gaz russe ça fait
monter le prix du gaz etc ce qui fait
pas vos affaires j'entends bien c'est
pour expliquer un peu les raisons ils
sont pas des raisons de décisions
politiques locales et plutôt des raisons
qu'on assume en tout cas on assume les
les motifs pour lesquels on a décidé
d'arrêter d'acheter du gaz russe c'est
qu'on veut protéger la population
ukrainienne et éviter que le conflit ne
s'enlise donc ce qu'on fait au niveau
européen et la France est très active
là-dessus on a obtenu des avancées qui
seront bientôt visibles concrètement
c'est qu'on peut plafonner le prix du
gaz et de l'électricité et qu'on veut
enlever tous les mécanismes qui
provoquent une forme de dérégulation du
rapport entre le gaz et l'électricité là
c'est en cours c'est en cours des
engagement qui ont été pris c'est vrai
qu'il y a une urgence on voit déjà que
le prix de l'électricité cyril a baissé
par rapport à ce qu'il était vous avez
raison de dire qu'il était monté à fois
cette fois dix aujourd'hui on est dans
des horizons qui sont plutôt de l'ordre
de x 3 et on s'attend à ce que ça baisse
de la même manière même si c'est pas
pour les mêmes raisons et pas les mêmes
mécanismes on s'attend à ce que le prix
d'un certain nombre de matières
premières qui s'était envolées je
pensais à lui le beurre etc reviennent
dans des eaux plus normales